pundits see Bastian Schweinsteiger as a  leader someone the German team turns to  when things aren't going too well on the  pitch now at age 30 shrine Steiger has  become the captain of the German team he  was born and bred in Bavaria he's been  playing for Bayern Munich since he was  14 he won two national youth  championships and that streak continued  in the Bundesliga and at the World Cup  we've got a fourth star thanks for the  support he's won the World Cup and the  Champions League trophy the FIFA Club  World Cup and the UEFA Super Cup  he's a seven-time winner of the German  championship and League Cup a record  Schweinsteiger has racked up 322  Bundesliga matches and 108 appearances  with the national team and he was  Germany's Footballer of the year in 2013  he's still missing one trophy that of  the European Championship he's gunning  for that one in 2016  you